The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
IAIN STEWART: So
last time, we were
talking about regularization
and power counting.
And in particular, we were--
we argued that there
some things that
are nice about dimensional
regularization when you're
doing dimensional power
counting, which is what we've
been discussing so
far, power counting
and ratios of mass scales.
So I want to continue
along that theme today,
and in particular move
towards really talking
about matching calculations
in the context of mass
of particles.
So just continuing
with this discussion
of dimensional regularization,
we also have to pick a scheme.
And the scheme that
is a nice scheme
for dimensional regularization
is this MS bar scheme.
There are some things
that are good about it.
Well, it's good because
it works under the context
of dimensional regularization
and preserves--
and it doesn't mess up
any of the nice things
about that regulator.
So it preserves symmetries--
gauge, symmetry,
Lorentz symmetry,
the things we
mentioned last time.
In terms of doing
calculations, it
makes them technically
easy, or easier.
So a lot of--
if you look at the
literature and you
look at multi-loop
calculations, they're
all done on the MS bar scheme.
And there's a reason for
that, because you've only--
you haven't introduced
these extra scales
that would make your loop
calculations more complicated.
And finally, in the
context of our discussion
of effective field theory,
it's nice because it often
gives what I would call
manifest power counting,
where we can power count
both the regulator diagrams,
the renormalized diagrams.
We don't have to worry
about whether we've
added the counter terms or not.
We can just do power counting.
So if there's some good,
there should be some bad.
So what's the bad?
Nothing is free in life.
So one thing that
we kind of lose
with dimensional regularization
is the physical picture.
When we had this cutoff
that we introduced,
or if we have a
Wilsonian picture,
it's very clear what
you're doing as far
as removing degrees of freedom.
And in MS bar, that's
a little less clear.
So if it's just less
clear but it's still fine,
that would be--
that would just be
a technical aspect
and we would just
pretty much ignore it.
So what's one--
I'll give you one
example of something
in which the picture
being less clear
could actually mislead you.
So if you calculate some
renormalized quantities
in MS bar, you could have
some a-priori knowledge
that these renormalized
quantities should be positive.
Maybe they're supposed
to be kinetic energy
or some operator,
higher-dimension operator, that
gives a kind of
higher-order kinetic energy
term, some kind of
physical intuition
that it should be positive.
Well, that might not
be true in MS bar
because MS bar loses
this physical picture.
You're removing just
the 1 over epsilons.
You're not really having any
control over the constants,
or the constants are
kind of predefined.
If those constants are
kind of too negative,
then you can end up with
renormalized matrix elements
in MS bar that
could be negative,
your physical intuition tells
you they should be positive.
So that's something
to be aware of.
Where a physical picture
could guide you and tell you
what to expect, but you might
lose that by using MS bar.
There's another thing
that's kind of technical
but is worth knowing.
And we will talk about it
a little bit more later.
You could ask the question,
is the Wilsonian picture
and the Wilsonian
scale separation
really equivalent to
the scale separation
that you do in dimensional
regularization?
And the answer is,
almost but not quite.
It certainly is for
all the log terms.
And I mentioned last
time that the log terms
that we saw in the two ways
of doing the calculation,
you could just see a direct
correspondence between them.
But there's a leftover
residual effect
called renormalons that does
show up in the MS bar scheme
and is related to
power divergences.
And so this effect
is carefully hidden.
It's actually hidden
in the asymptotics
of the expansion in alpha s.
And it goes under the
rubric of something
that people call renormalons.
So there is a leftover
physical effect
from kind of having the
freedom to drop all the power
divergent terms.
But it carefully hides
itself in a strange place
in the gauge theory.
And we'll talk more
about this later.
It's not so important if you're
working to order alpha s.
But if you start working toward
alpha squared or higher, then--
or if you start going to higher
orders in perturbation theory,
then this could come
in and be important.
And it does come in in
QCD at fairly low orders.
At order alpha squared, it
can cause numerical effects
if you ignore this.
And there are ways of taking
it into account without losing
the nice things here.
So we'll talk about
that later on.
And then there's a final thing--
we had three good points, we
should have three bad points--
the final thing we'll
deal with right now.
And that is the fact
that MS bar does not
satisfy something
that's a theorem called
the decoupling theorem.
So what is the
decoupling theorem?
So this goes back to
Appelquist and Carrazone.
And it says the following.
So you're thinking about
an effective field theory,
you're thinking about deriving
a low-energy effect of field
theory by integrating out
some mass of particle.
And the decoupling theorem
says that if the remaining
low-energy theory
is renormalizable,
and we use a physical
renormalization scheme,
then you kind of
get what expect,
that all the effects
of the heavy particles
turn up in couplings or
effects, they're suppressed.
So this seems very
physical from what
we've described about what
effective field theories do.
So in that sense, it's--
I'm not going to try to
prove it to you or anything,
but there is this
caveat that you
need to use a physical
renormalization scheme,
of which MS bar is not one.
So we decided that
we liked MS bar,
but then we found some problems.
And this problem here,
this last problem, we're
going to deal with right away.
So MS bar is not physical.
And hence, it doesn't
satisfy this theorem.
It's mass-independent.
And that is something
that we like,
but it also is causing
exactly this problem.
That's how it-- it's why
it violates the decoupling
theorem.
Because it's
mass-independent, it
doesn't know enough
about the mass
to know that the effect
of massive particles
should always decouple.
So in MS bar, what
you have to do
is you have to implement
that decoupling by hand.
And we've gotten actually
so used to this logic
that it's often even
not mentioned that this
is something that we're doing.
So go over that a bit.
So I'll just go over
this in the context
of a particular
example, which is
the most common
QCD with massive
particles in MS bar.
And I'll show you how it works.
So QCD has a beta function
of the renormalized coupling
mu d by d mu of g of mu.
And just to establish
some notation,
I'm going to remind you of some
facts that you've seen before.
So this is the beta
function at lowest order.
I'll call this factor
that depends on the group
that you're dealing with and how
many light fermions you have,
I'll call it b0.
And this is less than 0.
And this is only the
first-order term in a series,
but it'll be enough for
our discussion right now.
So this is g to the
fifth terms, et cetera.
That's the beta function for g.
We can also think about using--
since g likes to come squared,
we can switch to alpha.
QCD is asymptotically free.
When we solve this equation
for alpha, it looks as follows.
And the coupling
constant decreases
as you go to higher energy.
So this is alpha at md,
and this is alpha at mW.
Alpha at mW is less
than alpha at md.
This is the
lowest-order solution.
So just a little bit more in
the way of setting the stage,
you can also associate to this
solution here an intrinsic mass
scale dimensional transmutation.
If you form the
combination mu exponential
of minus 2 pi over beta 0--
b0 alpha of mu, and you use
this equation over here,
then what you'll find is
that this combination is also
equal to mu 0, same
thing alpha of mu 0.
So it's independent of what
choice of scale you use, mu
or mu 0.
Therefore, you define
it to be a constant,
and that constant is
called lambda QCD.
Once you do that, you can
also just take this equation
and write it like this.
Write that, rewrite
that solution like this.
So it's another way of
specifying a boundary
condition, if you like, for
the differential equation.
One way is to pick a value
of the coupling somewhere,
another way is to
fix this constant.
So this guy is independent
of mu, as I said.
And it's the scale where
QCD becomes nonperturbative.
And the reason I
have to mention this
is because we're
going to be talking
about anomalous
dimensions, and I
have to tell you when the things
that I write down are valid.
And it's all going
to be valid as long
as we're not near this scale.
Because if we're
near this scale,
the coupling gets
too large for us
to do the perturbation theory
that we're doing when we
calculate anomalous dimensions.
So you can ask the question,
what does this thing depend on?
And if we look at the
right-hand side here,
we can already see some
things it depends on,
because it depends on b0.
And if we looked back at what
b0 is, b0 depended on the fact
that we were at su3 if it's QCD.
It also depended on the
number of light flavors.
So this scale that
you fix here, well, it
depends on the order
of the loop expansion.
We wrote down a formula that
was valid at first order,
but we could extend that formula
at higher orders as well.
And the formula would
change, and the value
would change if we
went to higher orders.
Depends on the number
of light flavors.
And it actually also starts
to depend on the scheme
but only at two loops.
So it'll depend on
MS bar versus MS,
for example, but only
beyond two loops.
Now, the issue with this is
that a priori, nothing tells us
whether if you have
a top quark or an up
quark or a bottom quark.
In MS bar, nothing
a prior tells us
what to do with these formulas,
what to include in the b0.
Just seems like we should
include everything that exists,
all the known light fermions
that couple to the gauge field.
But there might be some
we don't know about.
Should we include those, too?
MS bar, with the logic
we've presented so far,
doesn't tell us what to
include there in that nf.
So let me phrase it this way.
But the top quark
and the up quark,
which have very different
masses, both contribute to b0.
And it seems like they
do that for any mu.
Even though-- even if I'm
at a very low-energy scale
and the top is
very heavy, MS bar
is not smart enough to
decouple the top quark.
If you were to work
in a physical scheme,
then this decoupling theorem
guarantees, actually,
that the top quark
would decouple,
and it would drop out of the
beta function in that scheme.
But in this MS bar
scheme, it doesn't happen.
So the solution to
this is to build back
in the thing that happened
in the physical schemes
into our MS bar scheme.
And we do that by implementing
the decoupling by hand.
And we just say that when
we get to a mass threshold,
we're going to integrate out
the heavy fermion in this case.
So at some scale of order
of the mass of that fermion,
we're going to integrate
out the heavy fermion.
And that's an example of
during matching, actually.
You're moving from
one theory to another,
because you're changing
the field content.
You're removing some
fields, and that's
an example of doing matching.
So what this means is that
we'll define different b0's
depending on what
scale we're at.
So nf would be 6 if we're at
scales above the top quark.
But then we drop
that nf down to 5
once we're below the top
quark mass, et cetera.
So it's a discrete
jump in what the b0 is.
So in some sense,
what that means
is that this kind of matching
is forced upon you in order
to preserve physics in MS bar.
If you were to do some other
scheme like a physical scheme,
it's not to say that you
couldn't take the same logic.
You could do matching to
integrate our heavy particles
in those schemes as well.
And in fact, some
sometimes people have.
But in MS bar It's
really forced upon you.
There's no way out,
because you otherwise
wouldn't get the physics right.
So we've got to be careful.
If you gain something,
sometimes you lose something.
And if it's physics
that you're losing,
you have to build it back in.
OK.
So how do we actually
do this matching?
Well, we use what are
called matching conditions.
So what is a matching condition?
At some scale which
I'll call mu m--
that could be equal to
m, but it could also
be equal to twice m or 1/2 m,
some scale that's of order m--
we're going to demand
something about the theory
above and below.
And that is that S matrix
elements in the two theories
are going to agree.
Of course, we should
be careful to make sure
that we work within
the realm of things
that we can calculate in
the low-energy theory.
So we should consider
only S matrix elements
with light external particles.
If we're getting rid
of the heavy ones,
we don't want them on
the external lines.
So the basic idea is that we
set up matching conditions which
are conditions that say that
S matrix elements should agree
between theories 1 and 2,
what we called theories 1
and 2 last time.
So if we do that
for QCD, the example
we've been talking about,
and we do it at lowest order,
then the conditions
are actually very easy.
So here's the picture.
Let's imagine that the top quark
is here, bottom quark is here.
My picture is not to scale.
Charm quark, et cetera.
Then what we do when we
want to say that the theory
above and below, that that
threshold is the same, if we
just match QCD above and below,
it just gives a continuity
condition on alpha.
So let me write it
down at this scale.
So here we would have alpha 6.
Alpha depends on the
number of flavors.
Here we have alpha 5.
A different definition
of the coupling
a different number
of active flavors,
a different value of b0.
3.
And what these arrows
are representing
are just kind of
renormalization group evolution,
which I'll just call running.
And then what the
lines are representing
is doing some matching.
So every time we reach a
threshold, we do a matching,
we switch the field
contact, and we
get a new effective field theory
with a new coupling constant.
So the coupling just depends
on what theory content we have.
And the matching condition
is, say, at this b quark scale
that alpha s at 5 at some
scale that's of order mb
is equal to alpha s at 4.
That's the leading order
matching condition here.
And similarly, the same
condition at all scales.
And this is mu b,
just to be clear,
is something that's of order
mb, could be equal to mb,
could be equal to mb/2,
could be twice mb.
And sometimes people use
these different choices
to get uncertainties.
OK.
So it seems fairly
straightforward,
just continuity of the coupling.
But that has some caveats.
But go ahead and
ask the question.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So how do you know that
that's the physical observable
that you care about?
What if I was trying to measure
the [INAUDIBLE] alpha s?
IAIN STEWART: So this is the--
yeah.
So if you're going--
so you have to think about it as
not the derivative of alpha s,
but you have to think about
it as an S matrix element--
something two-to-two
scattering, right?
If you do two-to-two
scattering, then it's
just going to be
proportional to alpha of mu.
But the mu dependence in
your leading order prediction
is not really fixed.
You need to go to
higher order to do that.
So if you're just
ensuring continuity
at leading order of
S matrix elements,
then this is all you need.
And if you want to
construct something that's
like a derivative
of alpha, you have
to think of the derivatives
of the S matrix.
But you can't take
derivatives of mu,
because that's a
higher-order question.
So this is all you
need at leading order.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So maybe my derivative example
is [INAUDIBLE] necessarily know
the alpha s, you'd get only--
IAIN STEWART: So in general--
right.
AUDIENCE: --but I don't
necessarily know that--
IAIN STEWART: Yeah.
No, in general, you have to--
this is like one
particular example.
In general, you have to ensure
continuity of all S matrix
elements.
And that will-- in
this case, we'll
give you conditions also
and what's happening
with masses and stuff.
So it's all the
parameters of the theory.
There should be conditions
for all of them.
AUDIENCE: I guess these
words seem more complicated
than just asking for [INAUDIBLE]
some different equation.
Does it ever boil
down to anything--
do you ever have to do anything
more complicated than just
like--
IAIN STEWART: I'm just--
yeah, so--
AUDIENCE: --change the beta
function [INAUDIBLE] continuity
and--
IAIN STEWART: It's really--
it's not complicated.
It's just continuity
of S matrix elements.
But you have to just know that
it's S matrix elements and not
the Lagrangian.
Because those are
two different things.
So let me give you an example
why it's not the Lagrangian.
So this kind of thing
seems simple, right?
Just say, well, the
Lagrangian is continuous.
The alpha-- the g that
appears in the Lagrangian
is continuous.
But that's not true once
you go to higher orders.
That's only a leading
order statement.
If I write down the analog
of this condition at higher
orders, it looks as follows.
So the coupling is actually
not continuous at MC bar
at higher orders.
So demanding continuity
of the S matrix elements
does not lead to
continuity of the coupling.
And the matching condition at
some scale looks like this.
So the words are carefully
crafted to be correct.
And they sound a
little more complicated
than they need to be, because
I want them to be correct,
even if I want--
even if I were to do matching
at higher orders in perturbation
theory.
And it's really at this
alpha squared level
that you start to see things
a little more interesting.
OK.
So now we've gone two
others beyond what I just
told you before.
So continuity at lowest order--
at the next order, you
can retain continuity
as long as you pick the
particular point where
mu b is equal to mb.
And you'd have-- then
this log would go away,
and you'd still have continuity.
But even that doesn't work
out once you go to one higher
order, there's this constant.
You could get rid of the logs
by picking a scale choice,
but there's no
scale choice which
will make it continuous once
you get to alpha squared
in this matching condition.
So this is the condition that's
necessary to ensure continuity
of S matrix elements
once you get
to that level of
perturbation theory.
OK, so that is why I
said S matrix and not
just continuity of couplings.
AUDIENCE: So this condition
is for 2-by-2 scattering,
And then you get
other conditions--
IAIN STEWART: This
is the only condition
you need for all the S matrix--
you can use different
S matrix elements,
and they'll lead to
the same condition.
AUDIENCE: How did you--
where does it come from?
IAIN STEWART: So this,
it comes from ensuring
that I calculate S
matrix elements, say,
2-to-2 scattering, in the theory
with five flavors and four
flavors.
AUDIENCE: At two loops?
IAIN STEWART: And I demand
that-- yeah, up to two loops.
So where would this
guy here come from?
This guy here would
come from the graph
with an explicit
b quark, which is
in the theory with the b quark
but not in the theory without.
Once you get to this
level, then there's
more complicated diagrams.
Just think of
generalizations of this.
And they involve
constants as well as logs.
This guy just involves a log.
And really, what
you're ensuring is
that in the theory
with the b quark, which
is this five-flavor theory,
you get the same S matrix
elements as in the
theory with four flavors.
Since the diagrams differ
in those two theories,
they're kind of the
same at lowest order
because you're just
doing two graphs.
But once you have the b
quark and it can go around
in the loop, then they
differ, and the conditions
become more complicated.
So any other
questions about that?
OK.
So one other thing
that we see from this
is related to these logarithms.
We also see from
these conditions
here that there is going to
be no large logarithms as
long as we pick the scale
where we do this matching to be
of order mb.
So you don't want to pick
mu to be the gut scale
or something you want to pick
it to be some scale so mu
is equal to mu b,
which is of order mb.
Because you don't
want, for example,
to make this log so
large that it starts
to overcome the coupling.
You want it to be--
you want this to really
be a perturbative
thing so it makes sense
to think about this, and
then this is a correction,
and that's another correction.
OK.
So the general procedure
is the same idea.
So if I just kind of adopt
a more general procedure
for massive
particles [INAUDIBLE]
a more general notation.
So this is with any
operators and couplings.
It doesn't have to
be gauge theory.
And if we have a
hierarchy of particles--
let's say we have n of them--
when we want to pass from an
L1 to an L2, an L3, to an Ln--
and we're doing the same type
of thing we just did over there.
So the steps are the following.
Consider S matrix
elements in theory 1.
Do so at a scale which I'll
call mu 1 that's of order m1,
and match that onto in the same
way of assuring the continuity
and do-- using these matching
conditions, match that onto L2.
So this is the
technical step by which
I said that you could do--
you could in a top-down
approach take theory 1
and determine the
parameters of theory 2.
The matching conditions are
determining the parameters.
Alpha s 4 is of parameter
of theory 2 to alpha s 5.
This is theory 1.
And we're just determining
what this alpha s 4 should be,
and this is the condition
that relates them.
So after you do
that step, if you
want to go through
this picture here,
or the analog of that picture
for this case over here,
then you need to compute
the beta functions
in anomalous dimensions
in this theory.
So it's the theory that
doesn't have particle 1.
And then you evolve/run
the couplings down,
which just means
using the evolution
equation for the couplings,
whatever they may be.
So we had the evolution
equation for alpha S a minute
ago on the board.
And I would just use that to
go from a scale of order mb
down to a scale of order mc.
And then I repeat.
And this is the general
kind of paradigm
of matching and running that you
hear about in effective theory
all the time.
So we just keep going.
And at the end of the day,
we're going to stop somewhere.
And the place
we're going to stop
is the place we want to
do lower-energy physics.
So let's say we stop
at the n-th level,
since that's the
last level I wrote.
So if you're interested
in dynamics at that scale,
that's where you stop.
And that's where you compute
your final matrix elements.
So everything up
until that stage
is just to determine
the theory Ln
and what are the values of
decoupling in that theory--
determined from knowing
information at the high scale.
Knowing information
in theory 1, how
do I propagate that
knowledge all the way down
to low energies
consistently without losing
information I need?
And then once I'm
at the lowest scale,
I just do my computations
of observables.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Professor.
IAIN STEWART: Sure.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] mention at
the scale where the particle is
there--
actually, I was a bit
confused because if we
write the full
theory, then, say,
2-to-2 scattering
in that mass scale,
isn't there any like [INAUDIBLE]
say resonance effect,
and then you want to
match that to a theory
without the particle?
I thought we should
match the s--
IAIN STEWART: So there
is no resonance effect.
And the reason is because the
momentum on the external lines
that you're taking--
you're thinking of
it as small, right?
The scale is chosen
to be the mass
of the particle, the
cutoff, mu, the soft cutoff.
But not the momentum
of the particles.
Good question.
Any other questions?
OK.
So we're not really done
talking about subtleties here.
And we're not really
done talking about some
of the key ideas that come
into these calculations.
I've given you a very simple
example just the coupling.
That's a little bit too simple.
So I want to do
something a little more
sophisticated but still
fairly simple and widely used.
And that is in the
standard model just
to take the heaviest
particles, which
are the top, the Higgs, the
W, and the Z, and remove them.
So we'll spend a bit of
time talking about what
happens when you do that.
That's not the only
thing you could do.
And in particular, before people
do how heavy the Higgs was,
you could think of
other possibilities.
And before people knew
how heavy the top was,
people did think of
other possibilities.
This is actually a reasonable
thing to do, though.
let me give you one example
of another possibility.
Or you could say the top is
heavier than the W and the Z,
so why don't I do the
top first, and then
I'll just follow your
diagram over there.
I erased it, but it'd
follow the picture.
And then I'll do some
running in the theory
without the top
quark, and then I'll
get down to the W
and the Z scales,
then I'll remove
the W and the Z.
OK.
That would be a
valid thing to do.
But it introduces complications
that are actually not
worth the effort.
And benefit is actually
not that great.
So I want to emphasize that.
When should you think of things
as being comparably heavy
versus when should you think
of things being hierarchically
heavy?
Well, one complication
of removing the top quark
is that it breaks su2
cross u1 gauge invariance,
because the top quark was
in a doublet with the b,
and you're trying to keep the
b and remove the top, which
doesn't sound good.
You're trying to keep the gauge
particles, the W and the Z,
in your theory.
So you should still have
that gauge symmetry, even
if it's spontaneously broken.
But you're trying to remove
one member of a doublet.
And that leads to
[INAUDIBLE] terms
that you'd have to clue
to the effective theory
so you can deal with it.
And it's just a
little bit annoying.
But, you know, it's
something you can deal with.
The real crux of the
matter is that if you
compare mZ over m
top, or mW over m top,
that's about a half.
So if you think
about what you're
expanding in when you take
external particles that
have momentum of order mZ,
integrate out particles
of order mt, you're expanding
in a half, which is not such
a great expansion parameter.
Usually in effective
field theory,
you want to expand in something
that's at least a third,
hopefully a quarter.
And a tenth if you really
want to have a good expansion.
So half is not really that good.
So that's the real
reason not to do it.
And you could ask, well, why
do we lose by not doing that?
And that, of course,
is the real question.
Well, you miss some
running, right?
Because you don't have a
theory that has no top quark
but still has a W and
a Z, and that theory
could have anomalous
dimensions, and you'd
miss any running in that theory.
You're kind of collapsing two
of the lines in my picture
with the arrow between,
you're collapsing them
down to just a single line.
So you're missing the running
that would go between mt to mW.
Well, of course, that's
not a very big hierarchy,
and it's logs of two.
And that's why we
don't care that much.
What it boils down to is that
you're treating alpha s at mW.
And if we want to
be generous, we
can say it's mW squared
over m top squared.
So they're logs of four.
But you're treating
this perturbatively.
If you remove both the top
and the W at the same time,
then this is going to show up
in your matching conditions,
and you're not thinking of
that is something as large.
Thinking of it just as order 1.
So that's the cost,
which is not a big cost.
Especially when you
give, say, that the cost
of going the other way would
be expanding in the half.
Better to take the
cost in the logarithms
than expansion in the half.
So that's a general
kind of rule,
that if you're thinking about
removing massive particles,
you should ask, how close
are they to each other?
Should I integrate out a slew
of them at the same time,
or one at a time?
That'll depend on exactly
the scales in the problem.
And there's-- and it means
you're organizing the theory
differently if you do it,
the two different approaches.
All right.
So we'll do an example of this.
We'll take a very
simple example,
although not completely trivial.
So just b quarks changing
to charm quarks u bar and d.
So on the standard model,
which is where we start,
let's say we have a W boson.
We have an up quark
that's left-handed.
We have a CKM matrix
connecting flavors together.
And we have down quarks.
So this is-- there's
a matrix space here
in the flavor, which includes
bottom charm up and down.
And tree level matching is easy.
And some of the complications
I want to talk about
will come into the loops.
So let's first get
through the tree level
and set up some notation.
And then we'll talk about
what happens with the loop.
So tree level, this is the
diagram in the theory 1.
Just calculate it at tree level.
W propagator, unitary gauge.
And then there's some spinners.
So we have an antiquark.
So we have a v spinner
for the antiquark.
That's an up.
Everything else is a u spinner.
I've put in explicitly
the P lefts to denote
the fact that it's left-handed.
So there's some momentum
in this diagram, which
is momentum transfer, which
is the be momentum minus the c
momentum and the kind
of obvious notation.
And of course, by
momentum conservation,
that's also the d momentum
plus the u momentum.
And that's the momentum that's
going through the propagator.
We're going to count momenta
as being of order masses.
And the heaviest mass in this
case is the b quark mass.
And we'll take it to
be the b quark mass.
We can use the
equations of motion.
So Pb slash on ub,
spinner for the b quark
is mb ub, et cetera.
And we can simplify the
diagram by doing that.
And of course, the
key thing is that we
can expand the propagator
since the momentum is smaller
than the mass of the
W for integrating out
the W. So the leading term
when we do that is this term.
And any other terms that we
drop are down by that much.
So for example, this
term here, we just
said that the k's are of
order mb so it's down.
And then we could drop
the k squared here,
I'll get the mW squared,
so we just have that.
And then we put that together,
we can calculate the Feynman
rule in the effective theory.
The Feynman rule in
the effective theory,
we can determine the
coefficient of it.
So let's start out
with just saying
it's some four-quark operator
that couples together
those flavors, conveniently
chosen so that they're all
different to avoid
[INAUDIBLE] factors.
And in some conventional
normalization
for this Wilson coefficient, we
call it GF, which is for Fermi.
And the Feynman rule
would again give spinners,
the same spinners as before,
with the same Lagrangians
for these light quarks.
Haven't changed
anything about that.
We're just removing
the heavy particle.
And it's conventional
also to pull out
the CKM factor [INAUDIBLE].
OK.
So if you like, you can say
that there's a coefficient here,
and that coefficient
has been fixed to be 1.
And what this G Fermi
is, then, would just
be the leftover factors
of the gauge coupling
and the mass of the W. And
that's the usual convention.
So G Fermi is just fixed in
this case, not as the thing that
is going to get corrected
at higher orders in QCD
but would get corrected at
higher orders in electroweak,
if you like.
And then you sort of put
in with the QCD corrections
into some other coefficient
that we can call C.
And we'll just say that
it's 1 at the level of this.
And this line agrees with
the expansion of that line,
and that's the
matching of something
that's measurable, which is
this four-point function.
So we can call it
an S matrix element.
So this theory is very popular.
It's called the
electroweak Hamiltonian.
It's used all over the place.
And it involves more than
just doing what I did,
because I chose a
particular set of flavors
for a particular
channel, and you
have to do it for the whole--
for all sorts of other
channels as well.
So we'll study some
aspects of this theory.
We won't study every
possible aspect.
But I've given you a handout
that studies a lot more.
It's 250 pages long.
I'm not asking you to
even read all of that.
I've pointed you at
some pages of that
in the reading, which are
relevant to the discussion
we're having here.
If you really want to
dig deeper, you can.
So people often call this an
electroweak Hamiltonian, which
is just minus the Lagrangian.
So then that's 4 GF over 2.
And as a Hamiltonian, we write
fields instead of spinners.
So we have this
four-quark operator.
And we would have determined
the Hamiltonian from tree level
matching, from what we've done.
And this would be the
result. Standard stuff.
How do we want to go
further than that?
Well, if we want to think about
theory 2, which is this theory,
and we want to think
about it in more detail,
we should worry
about whether we're--
with just this
operator, whether we've
got a complete set of structures
that could possibly occur.
So we should think
about the symmetries.
And it's useful to, therefore,
construct the most general
basis of operators in theory 2.
And we'll just do that.
So if you read this
250-page review,
then it's done for the full
electroweak Hamiltonian,
and we'll just stick
with the flavors
we're talking about here.
So what are the most
general bases of operators?
How should we think about that?
Well, we're
constructing some theory
that's going to-- that we're
matching onto it mu equals mW.
And at that scale, when
we're determining the theory
and determining the
coefficients of the theory,
we can treat the bottom
the charm the down
and the up respectively
as if they're massless.
And really, what I mean by that
is that the masses of these
particles are only going to
show up in the operators and not
in the coefficients,
which I've--
you see that I talked
about over here.
The thing that shows
up in the coefficients
are the mass scales
we're removing.
And we're not removing the
mass scales of these things.
So that means, if we can
think of them as massless,
that we can think about the
matching in terms of using
something like chirality.
And we can use the fact
that QCD for massless quarks
does not change chirality.
And we can use that in
constructing our basis.
So that means even though the
b quark and the charm quark
really have masses, for
the purpose of constructing
the operator basis, we can
think of them as massless.
And we only have left-handed
guys to worry about here.
Chirality means more than that.
It also-- well, it
means effectively that.
But it means also that we will
only get one gamma matrix here.
And we can think
about why that is.
Chirality means that
you get an odd number.
You need an odd number to
have left on both sides.
But you can reduce 3 to 1.
So there's an identity which
I won't write out for you,
but you can reduce
3 back down to 1.
So any higher odd number can
be reduced back down to 1.
So once we use
chirality and that fact,
then we have a fairly
restrictive basis
in terms of Dirac structures.
You could ask, what are the
most general possible ways
of contracting spinner indices?
Who said I had to put this charm
quirk with the bottom quark?
I could have put the
up quark over here.
And maybe in higher
orders that happens.
Well, at higher
orders, you could
think about that happening.
But you can always
get back to the form
that I wrote over there using
what's called the spin Fierz.
So if I write it
for fields, it means
that there's an identity
that I can rearrange
this guy the other way.
And so these are
equivalent operators.
And sometimes, you have
to use these relations
when you're doing
matching calculations,
because you construct
a complete basis, which
is the minimal one.
And then maybe when you
do your calculation,
you get this
operator, so you have
to turn it back into this one.
There's two minus
signs in this relation.
One is from the Fierz
identity, and one
is because when you
do the manipulations
you end up
anticommuting to fields.
So from the statistics.
So if you were to use the
same relation for spinners,
then there would be
one less minus sign.
Something to be careful, though.
So what this tells you, once you
put that information together,
is that you know that you can
write the operators this way,
and you also know that
this gamma, capital gamma,
has that gamma u p left form in
terms of the Dirac structure.
So the only really thing
that can happen is color.
And you can contract
the color of these 3's--
so you have four 3's, you can
contract the color of them
in different ways.
Well, I have two 3
bars and two 3's.
Think about having different
color contractions.
And that will expand
our operator basis
by one more operator.
There is also a color Fierz.
And I can use that color Fierz
to get rid of having explicit
TA's.
So color is a lot
like spin in the sense
that if I had more
TA's, then I can always
reduce a higher number of TA's
back down to a lower number.
So I've had two, I can reduce
it down to one or zero.
OK.
So I only really have to
think about having a TA here
and a TA there.
If I have a TA there and a
TA there, there's a spinner--
or there's a color Fierz
relation for this guy
that you could use.
And there's a
handout that I posted
on the web that has a summary
of all these relations.
I'm not going to bother writing
them down in lecture here.
So once I take
that into account,
then it ends up
in two operators.
And if I were to write them in
a kind of renormalized notation
where I introduce
the scale mu, then I
would write them as follows.
Let's call them O1 and O2.
And the difference between O1
and O2 is just simply color.
So in O1, the color
index alpha is
contracted between charm
bottom and up down and up.
And then in O2
it's the the colors
contracted the other way.
So I don't write
explicit TA's, but I
do have to consider the other
possible way of contracting
the indices.
Up, down, doesn't matter.
OK.
So these operators, these are
the two operators they have
once I satisfy
all the symmetries
and I have some coefficients.
And if you ask really what
the coefficients can depend
on here, well, they can
depend on mass scales like top
and the other particles
that I'm integrating out,
Z. I'm not going to make
that explicit in my notation.
If I tried to make
every possible mass
scale like the Higgs or the
top, it would just be too much.
So let me just denote two
things that it can depend on.
Mu over mW can show
up, and alpha of mu
can show up, as well as some
ratios of other particles
which we will suppress.
So then what tree level
matching is saying
is that you've got one
of these operators,
and you didn't
get the other one.
So it says that at tree
level, what we did before--
and so say we do
matching at mu equals
mW and C1 at 1, which is mu over
mW equals 1 and alpha mW is 1.
And then corrections to
that would be suppressed,
no large logs, just by alpha.
And C2 of 1 alpha mW is 0
plus something of this order.
So that's what we determined by
doing our tree level matching.
Now, when we did our tree level
matching we did something.
We used external states
which were quarks.
We matched up the S matrix
elements in that way.
If you were really
interested in this process
b goes to c u bar
d, you'd not really
be interested in
measuring quarks.
We don't see them.
You'd be interested in thinking
about the process for mesons--
B meson changes to a D meson,
and a pion, for example.
And who's to say that the
matching that we did for quarks
is also the matching
that's valid for hadrons?
Well, it is.
So there's a key fact about
matching which is important.
One of the things I
wanted to emphasize to you
is that it doesn't depend
on what states you pick.
It's independent of
the choice of states.
And it's independent of the
IR regulators that you pick.
So when you do
matching, you often
pick some IR regulators to
regulate IR divergences.
And the only thing
you have to do
is pick the same states
and same IR regulators
in the two theories.
And once you do that, your
results for your coefficients
will be independent of
the choice you made.
So this is intuitively something
I think that's, once you
think about it, fairly obvious.
What this sentence is saying
is that the matching, which
is supposed to be a
high-energy property,
is independent of the
low-energy physics.
The choice of the states and
the choice of IR regulators,
that's parameterizing something
about low-energy physics--
lower energy than the scale
we're trying to determine.
These things should only depend
on higher-energy physics.
So the outcome for them will
be independent of this choice.
So just to emphasize, even
when we use hadronic states,
the result that we obtain
from quark states is valid.
That's just different
choice of state.
And what we're doing when
we do the matching is we're
picking a convenient choice
of state, something that
makes it easy to calculate.
If we tried to calculate the
matrix elements of B and D
and pi mesons, then I'm saying
if you're a strong enough,
you'd get the same
matching coefficient.
Of course, you should
pick the result
that makes the
calculation easy, and that
would be to use quarks.
Any questions about that?
OK.
So this is something that
you should keep in mind.
And you should keep
in mind that it is--
you do have to make
sure that you're
using the same states and IR
regulator in the two theories.
In this case,
that's pretty easy.
The states are really the
same states, because you're
defining the states with
the Lagrangian machine
for the b quarks, say,
and the b quark Lagrangian
hasn't really changed.
So there's no
change in the state.
And you can set things up
so that you have the same IR
regulator.
And that'll become
important in the example
that we're just about to do.
So let's do an example
of carrying out
this matching for C1 and
C2 in a little more detail.
And before we
carry out matching,
we actually have to
renormalize the two theories.
Well, we've been talking
as if the theory above
is the standard model.
So imagine that we've
already renormalized that.
And so we only
have to renormalize
the effective theory in MS bar.
So we'll talk about doing that,
remind you of doing that--
maybe something
you've seen before.
So there's going to be wave
function renormalization.
So you have this 4/3.
I'm going to leave out the
prefactor, this prefactor.
It's always going to be there.
I'm going to stop
writing it and start just
focusing on the thing
in square brackets here.
We'll do calculations
with Feynman gauge.
I'm not going to really
do the calculations.
I'm just going to
quote results to you.
And in order to simplify
what we have to write down,
let me define the
set of spinners
that you get from taking the
tree level matrix element of O1
to be S1 and of O2 to be S2.
So this is just the
spinners that we
wrote down before
for the case of S1,
exactly what we had before.
And then for S2, just a slightly
different contraction of color
indices.
OK.
So that's just trying to
make the lowest-error result
simple to write down so
that when I write down
the higher-error result, we
can focus on the things that
are changing and mattering, and
not on the complications that
come in from what
we're talking about.
So if we think
about diagrams here,
we have four-quark operator.
And we just have to draw
all the loop graphs Right.
We have to regulate
them in some way,
because they are IR divergent.
So let's regulate them with--
if we really want to talk
about the matching, which
is what I really want
to do eventually,
we should regulate
them in some way.
And so let's regulate them
with off-shell momenta
on the external lines.
And I'll take it to be a
common off-shell momenta p.
And I'll just set the
masses of the external lines
to 0, since they're
not going to matter.
OK.
So then what does it look like?
So the matrix element of O1--
the 0 means Bayer--
is going to have divergences.
And it has the following
structure, times spinner 1.
And then there's another
piece that involves spinner 1.
And then there's a piece that
involves spinner 2 that shows
up in from these loop graphs.
So even though we're calculating
the Bayer matrix [INAUDIBLE]
of operator 1, the
spinner combination 2
shows up, because this
is supposedly a gluon,
and the gluon moves
the color around.
And I'm only writing
the divergent terms,
although later on
we'll be interested
in the constant terms as well.
So the dots are the constant
terms underneath logarithms,
and all these little
round brackets
have constant terms in them.
Part of the reason
for introducing
the basis in the way
I did is that when
I want to quote you
the result for O2,
it's the same, just
switching 1 and 2.
And so the statement that
you would have from this--
these are ultraviolet
divergences,
the infrared divergences
are regulated.
The statement that you
would have from this
is that you can look at these
various terms, and you can ask,
what's going on with
those divergences?
Well, this one here is actually
cancelled by wave function
renormalization, which
I haven't put in yet.
And this one here is
O1 mixing into O1.
So this one here is a
counterterm, if you like,
for O1.
And this one here is
a counterterm for O2.
And the language you use as
you say that O1, which we're
calculating, has mixed into O2.
So there's two
different methods we
could use to carry out
the renormalization here
that are actually equivalent.
So method one is called
composite operator
renormalization.
It's useful to know what
things are equivalent so
that you know what you can
get away with ignoring.
So what is composite
operator renormalization?
Well, you think about
having a Bayer operator.
And you need to introduce
some constants to renormalize.
These are not related to wave
function renormalization.
It's actually operator
renormalization.
You have multiple fields at
the same spacetime point,
you need additional
renormalization constants,
that's what these Z's are.
When you go to take
the matrix element,
you have to include the wave
function renormalization
as well.
So the Bayer matrix element has
a wave function renormalization
as well as this Z. And
this is the relation
between the renormalized matrix
element and the Bayer one.
So this guy here is
renormalized and amputated.
OK.
So that's the relation
you can calculate O0.
That's what we were doing.
We just calculated O0.
We could remove Z psi.
And I just told you
if you remove Z psi,
it's going to get rid of this.
And then you use the remainder
of this stuff to get Zij.
I'm going to need it
the other way around.
So let me write the--
so I can write this relation
the other way around.
And then it looks like this.
OK, so that's one method.
The other one is related
more to how we usually
think about things in
terms of gauge theory.
And that is to have
counterterm coefficients
for the various operators.
So start with the Hamiltonian
written in terms of Bayer
coefficients and operators
that have Bayer fields--
Bayer operators, if you like.
And now switch over to
renormalized quantities,
so you get Z psi squared.
We have to switch over
from the Bayer coefficient
to a renormalized one.
So let me do that first.
So we get some Z
for the coefficient,
some renormalized coefficients.
And then we get a Z psi squared
from the four fermions that
are in this operator.
Then we get an O.
And then we can write this
in terms of Ci Oi plus Z psi
squared Zij C minus
delta ij Cj Oi.
And then this would
be our counterterms.
So we would stick in
this guy, that operator
we haven't renormalized--
we haven't done our operator
renormalization.
We're not doing method 1.
So this, the matrix element
here will still diverge,
but we cancel them off
with the counterterms.
So that's the logic of method 2.
And once you do
that, the divergences
cancel between these two terms,
and you're left, if you like--
or even if you don't--
with the coefficients
times the operators, which
are renormalized,
both renormalized,
even renormalized separately.
And these two are equivalent.
These are equivalent ways of
thinking about the same thing.
And we can even go further and
derive the equivalence of them.
So if we take this theory and
we take the matrix element
of the Hamiltonian in this
second way of doing things,
what do we get?
We get this.
So even though as Oi,
I said, we haven't
done operator
renormalization, so we still
have the divergences
there, that's Cj Oj.
And if we write the
OJ using the relation
at the top of the board,
then we get Cj Zji inverse Z
psi squared Oi 0.
And then we can just
look at the two sides.
They both have
the Z psi squared.
They both have a Cj,
they both have Oi 0.
The only thing that's
different is this.
So we find the Zij
for the coefficient
is the transpose of the inverse
of the Z's for the operators.
So that's a more definite
way of saying the two would
lead to the same results.
And this is how
you would actually
get the relation between
the two ways of doing it.
So it's not completely trivial.
You have to know you have to
take the inverse and transpose.
But it's the same information.
OK.
So in our example,
the Z is a matrix.
It starts out as
the unit matrix.
And in MS bar, we collect
the divergences that are not
cancelled by wave
function renormalization.
And that gives us this
little 2-by-2 matrix.
And from that little
2-by-2 matrix,
we can construct anomalous
dimension for the operators.
So let's do that.
So how do we do that?
Well, if we take the
renormalization of the Bayer
operators, remember those
dependent on the regulator,
but they didn't depend
on the scale mu.
So if we take mu
d by d mu of Oi 0,
which is the Bayer
operator at 0.
That's what I've written.
And then we can write
O in terms of the Z,
in the equation I raised.
And both Z and the
renormalized operator
depend on the scale mu.
And so that gives
us this equation.
So I'm doing method
1 here, if you like,
using the notations
from method 1.
If I take that equation
and rearrange it,
I can write it as
anomalous dimension
equation for the operator.
So it's mu d by d mu
is one of the terms.
I isolate this, and I
move that over by taking
an inverse of it.
And I just call
everything that I
get there the anomalous
dimension of the operator.
So gamma ji is all the
other stuff, Zjk inverse.
And I put the explicit
minus sign here
so there's no minus
sign in that equation.
Anomalous dimension is
determined by the Z factors.
And we determine the
Z factors, and which
we can stick this equation
into that equation
and get the anomalous dimension.
When we do that, we have to
be careful about the fact
that alpha s in d dimensions
has a little extra piece that's
actually important for
this discussion, which
is this piece.
So when we take mu d by d mu,
you ask, what depends on mu?
And it's the alpha here
that depends on mu.
And it's still in--
depends on epsilon as
well in that equation.
And so this term is the term
that matters at one loop.
And this matters at two
loops, and so does that.
But at one loop, we could just
replace this by the identity,
and we can drop this.
OK.
Put those things together.
Anomalous dimension,
of course, is something
that doesn't depend on epsilon.
And it's, in this
case, a 2-by-2 matrix.
And we can solve this problem.
If we want to solve this
matrix, then what do you do?
Well, you could diagonalize it.
That's how you would solve it.
So if you want to run the
operators in this theory just
for completeness,
you would diagonalize
by forming O1 plus or minus O2,
call the coefficients of those
new operators, C plus or
minus, and an obvious notation.
And when you write down
an anomalous dimension
equations for
these guys, there's
no mixing anymore at one loop.
In general, this
is the procedure
if you do this
diagonalization that you
have to carry out again
when you get to two loops.
It's not like the basis
that you pick at one loop
will be fine for two loops.
We're not so lucky.
But at one loop, this is
a perfectly valid basis
for the problem.
And in an hopefully
self-evident notation,
I either take all
pluses or all minuses.
OK.
And if I write my
Hamiltonian, I could write it
in the original basis.
Then if I switch
to the other basis,
I'll set up my convention
so that it's simple.
And that means I
picked C plus or minus
to be C1 plus or minus C2/2.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] minus?
IAIN STEWART: Whoops, thank you.
Yeah, they have
the opposite sign.
First one's positive,
second one's negative.
And in this new basis
tree level matching,
which is your boundary
condition for your revolution,
is that both
coefficients are 1/2.
OK.
So then we could solve
the differential equation
the same way we
were doing for QCD--
write down a result
that would sum
logs below the
scale of the W mass.
OK.
So we'll continue along
these lines next time,
say a few more words
about renormalization,
which is really just a
lead-up of doing the matching,
which is what I want to--
kind of the thing I want to
spend a little more time on.
So we'll finish that
up also next time
and move on to
some other things.
So there's a few
things to emphasize
when we do the matching.
And I want to write
down the matrix elements
and the full theory,
which are box diagrams,
I'll write down the
results for those.
We'll compare those
to the results
of the effective
theory, and we'll
draw some lessons from that.
And we'll carry
out the matching,
figure out what the next order
coefficients would be here.
What would those
alpha s terms be?
What's the procedure
I would go through
to get those coefficients?
OK.
So we'll stop there for today.